- THANKS, MAUREEN.
both: OH...HELLO.
- HOW ARE YOU?
I'M GEORGE ST. GEEGLAND.
- OH, CHARMED, I'M SURE.
I'M GIL FAIZON.
WHAT AM I SUPPOSED TO SAY?
- AND THIS IS OUR PRANK SHOW.
- AND THIS IS OUR PRANK SHOW,
TOO MUCH TUNA.
- EVERY WEEK ON
TOO MUCH TUNA, WE PRANK SOMEONE
BY GIVING THEM
TOO MUCH TUNA FISH.
- WHICH IS A DELICIOUS FISH.
- PRANKS ARE
THE HOT NEW THING.
FROM CANDID CAMERA TO BLOOPERS
AND PRACTICING JOKES.
- TO ASHRAM KITCHEN'S PRANTH'D.
- THIS WEEK OUR GUEST
IS OUR DEAR, DEAR FRIEND,
DR. JEFFREY GURIAN, D.D.S.
- JEFFREY GURIAN, YOU'VE LED
SUCH A FASCINATING LIFE.
DO TELL US ABOUT IT.
- WELL, YOU KNOW,
I HAVE LED A FASCINATING LIFE.
I WAS BORN IN NEW YORK.
I, UH, I WRITE.
I WRITE PROJECTS.
GURIAN NEWS NETWORK.
- OH.
- GNN.
- CAN I GET SHOT OF YOU TWO?
- YEAH.
- YEAH? OKAY. COOL.
[snaps picture]
ONE MORE.
- ONE WITH MY EYES CLOSED.
- YEAH.
[snaps picture]
- YOU KNOW, JEFFREY, YOU'RE ON
OUR PRANK SHOW,
TOO MUCH TUNA WHERE
WE'RE GONNA DELIVER
TOO MUCH TUNA FISH TO YOU.
- I MEAN, I--
- WELL LET'S JUST SEE
WHAT HAPPENS.
OH, THAT'S WONDERFUL.
THANK YOU.
- OKAY.
YOU'RE PROBABLY THINKING...
- YOU'RE PROBABLY...
- YOU'RE PROBABLY THINKING
THAT'S TOO MUCH TUNA.
- NO, I'M NOT
THINKING ANYTHING. NO.
I THINK IT'S GREAT.
- YOU TICKED OFF?
- NO, NOT AT ALL. IT'S--
- ARE YOU JUST HEATED AT US
FOR GIVING YOU
THIS MUCH TUNA?
- NOT AT ALL.
- TOO MUCH.
- WE'VE HAD A LOT OF GUESTS
ON TOO MUCH TUNA.
- AND THIS IS JUST
TOO MUCH TUNA.
- THIS IS FABULOUS.
- LISTEN, THAT'S TOO MUCH TUNA
AND WE JUST PRANKED YOU
BUT GOOD.
I MEAN, THERE'S
A CAMERA RIGHT THERE.
- LOOK, OH Y--
- YOU WANT ME TO LEAVE HERE?
- YOU'RE ON A PRANK SHOW.
THERE'S A CAMERA BEHIND YOU.
- I'M NOT LOOKING,
I'M NOT LOOKING.
- THERE'S A CAMERA OVER THERE.
- I'M NOT EVEN LOOKING.
- YOU'VE BEEN PRANKED.
YOU'RE SITTING HERE.
- HOW DO YOU FEEL?
- THE TUNA'S PERFECT.
- YOU'RE ON
A PRANK SHOW CALLED
TOO MUCH TUNA, JEFF, WHETHER
YOU LIKE IT OR NOT.
- NO, I'M NOT.